alright guys so for movie fans the
biggest time of the year is coming up
soon the summer and that's when all this
stuff happens when all the big movies
come out last year the summer was very
disappointing in the fall and the winter
kind of ruled everything but this year
there's no snow Christian and Mark are
two of my favorite movie reviewers on
YouTube I'm sure you subscribe to them
if you haven't I put a little link in my
channel box definitely check them out
they did a segment like this and it
really inspired me and I decided to make
my own so before we get into May coming
up pretty soon let's talk about four
major releases that are coming out that
month the first one we got to talk about
is Thor Jane I think you want to see
this the person this is actually my most
anticipated movie of May instructed by
Kenneth Branagh I'm not trying to say
that he's a very good director and it's
a really odd choice because he's never
really tackled like a huge studio movie
like this and I really like this film
much ado about nothing which came out in
the 90s and has like a huge ensemble
cast of like Denzel Washington Emma
Thompson Keanu Reeves and like a whole
bunch of different people but from what
I've seen from the trailers I really
think Chris Hemsworth is gonna do a good
job death threat to me
Thor so cute what he was freaking me out
where did he come me he said it was Thor
I liked him it a perfect getaway even
though he didn't really have that much
to do there I everyone know that love
Natalie Portman Anthony Hopkins is one
of my favorite actors so I'm looking
forward to for a lot I think it's gonna
be really good for once it really seems
like when those movies where the really
good parts in like the overall weight of
the story is left out of the trailer
which I really like because so often
that with trailers it just gives away
everything
I will return
a little bit later in May we have a
movie called priest starring Paul
Bettany which the first time I saw the
trailer I was like wait a second is this
legion - I'm not even kidding I
literally thought it was legion - and I
gratefully chose not to see ledin
because from what I hear it's one of the
worst movies that came out in 2010 and
it just seems odd that he's doing
another religiously themed creature
esque film so I don't really understand
that they get you come on why you're
gonna need it I'm not really looking
forward to this film at all I'm not even
sure if I'll see it to be honest I just
I'm not a huge Paul Bettany fan even
though I do think he's been good in
certain movies I don't really think it's
gonna make a lot of money because he's
not really a big box office draw and
after Legion I don't know if too many
people are gonna be excited to see him
in another film similar to that so I
don't know
probably fans of the graphic novel will
be interested in seeing it but let me
see a third of you say on that one no
it's just beginning
thanks for coming what my opinion is
probably gonna be the highest person
come of may Pirates of the Caribbean for
have you ever see with your own eyes the
Fountain of Youth
I'm sorry could you repeat the question
please
I love the first count I really really
love the first film to was okay three
was okay and I think this could be a
problem because a lot of audiences even
though a whole bunch of people went to
see to and made a lot of money overall
audiences I think we're kind of like I
don't know three even more so so I don't
know if the audience's will jump on to
four as much it's changing directors
it's not the director of the
oscar-winning Best Picture of musical
Chicago which is odd but Johnny Depp I
love Johnny Depp orlando bloom and keira
knightley element is gone he'll be Cruz
I don't know if I'm going to enjoy her
in this film she seems like she might
ignore me just from the trailer the
Rican come to life turned against us
captain I wish to report a mutiny I can
name fingers and point names
Ian McShane I'm sure you can play a
really good villain Geoffrey Rush's back
I really like him I'm hopeful that it'll
go in a different direction and
hopefully maybe revitalize the series a
little bit but I don't know what will
happen but generally if you hear parts
of the Caribbean and Johnny Depp in the
same sentence most of most likely kids
are gonna be like oh boy I think I'm
gonna see it so we'll see what happens
or part of the plan yes
the last weekend of May we have two
films that are big coming out Hangover
Part 2 and Kung Fu Panda 2 now you can
kill me for this but I am in no way
excited for Hangover Part 2 I haven't
even seen the first film in any clips
that I have seen from it I haven't
really laughed at all I just don't find
it very funny and I feel that from what
I've seen of it I think it's probably a
pretty over rate of the movie and I
don't even think I'll be seeing Hangover
Part 2 you can kill me for that whatever
however I am very interested in Kung Fu
Panda 2 from the universe from the
massacre oh yeah of course our greatest
masters are disappearing I fear this
that's a work of the Lord and who
listened least a new kind of threat time
I really enjoyed the first one Jack
Black has kind of had a losing streak in
regards to his feature films lately one
of the things I was most surprised about
by the first film was that the Kung Fu
element to it was actually a very
exciting I enjoyed the first a lot
hopefully this second one can still
maintain the comedy and the action
elements successfully so hopefully that
will be cool
you decide what size that's the month of
May towards the end of May I will cover
the month of June
Thor is my most anticipated movie
however I think pirates 4 will probably
take the crown regard some money what do
you guys think you can comment below
I'll see you at the end of May for my
June preview